foreign
[Music]
screening group my background is In
etymology and protein biochemistry and
today I'm going to talk to you about a
new technique we're working on with
Matt's back
analysis of high through profile
chemical cellular and protein assay so
thank you for inviting me to speak
this is my quick disclaimer slide you
can pause the presentation if you'd like
to read it and just for a little bit of
background let me set the stage for why
we're interested in the technology I'm
going to talk to you about today so when
when we think of high throughput
screening at least in Pharma we think of
a assay that's capable of running at
least a million compounds in about two
weeks that translates to one sample per
second or one well per second one
reaction per second
we need a kind of Holy Grail of htfs
they used to be fairly cheap so less
than five cents a while is what what we
shoot for we want it to be free of
detection artifacts we want to be robust
meaning it can uh the technology can run
uninterrupted for days weeks months
without extensive downtime
ideally it would have high information
content so we'd be able to do both
screens and counter screens in a single
essay and I'll explain a little bit more
about what that means later
um we want to we want it to be flexible
so we want to be able to be used for all
sorts of different targets different
assay types so biochemical or cell based
different analytes peptides lipids
metabolites macromolecules anything we
might look at in a biological system
um in terms of the high information
content the the graphics shown there the
kind of slider going from high
throughput to high information content
this is a typical Paradigm where if you
have very high throughput you typically
have a lot lower information content and
vice versa so on the far left the the
highest throughput assays we have now
such as being DNA encoded binding assays
only give a yes no answer whereas the
highest information Rich content are
very low throughput like lcms or or NMR
where you get very rich information
structural information or or information
on thousands of analytes but you can
only do a sample every couple minutes or
even every hour
the mass spectrometry in general is
information Rich it's label free and
also meaning it's cheap and detection
are effect free and it's also flexible
for lots of different analytes so
therefore it has kind of all the
potential to be the Holy Grail of an HCS
assay but traditionally throughput have
has been limiting Limited uh recently in
the last five years or so there have
been some new technologies based on mass
specs that have come out such as high
throughput moldy the the broker farmer
false or the echo-based Technologies
where they use an echo to
introduce the sample into the mass
effect so acoustic myths or open port
Technologies uh
commercialized by psyx so those are
those are also worth looking into and
I'd encourage you to look into those
Technologies as well on your own time
but today I'm going to talk about IR
maldezy Mass Spec Irmo Betsy stands for
infrared Matrix assisted laser
Distortion electrospray ionization
um so I'll explain exactly what that
means or the exact mechanism but what it
is really from our perspective and why
we're interested in it is that it's a
novel Mass Spec ionization method that's
applicable to label-free high throughput
assays and this is the important part
with little or no sample cleanup uh it's
not currently commercially available or
under development that we know of by a
instrument manufacturer it was
originally developed for Imaging Mass
Effect Imaging by a professor at North
Carolina State Dr David mudderman who
we're currently collaborating with here
at Abby
um and the the inspiration for Tran
using this right throughput screening
came while Dr mutton was presenting at
Abby back in 2016 he was explaining how
they how they run the experiment how
they take a tissue slice put it on a
slide freeze it and water acts
essentially is the Matrix to help
introduce the sample into Mass Spec or
help the laser excite the sample
um so the light bulb kind of went in on
in our head if he can do this with
tissues and he gets such Rich
information content is shown in the
inspector in the middle there why
wouldn't we be able to do this and at
the very least simple biochemical
reactions but hopefully cell-based acids
as well do it on on cells in my
protector plates
so that's exactly what we set out to do
um we've been collaborating with Dr
mudderman for five or six years now
we've been uh in 2017 we published the
first proof of concept with him uh of a
biochemical reaction out of micro cutter
plates so the merits of Ira maldez but
it is ambient so that
um it's just run in the in the open
environment it has a forgiving geometry
I'll explain a little bit more of that
the actual mechanism but it allows us to
directly sample from any well-plate or
Salad surface so we can sample from
microfatter plates we can sample the
surface of tablets we can sample tissue
slices it's very fast I'll show in a
couple slides and videos where we're
sampling more than 20 samples per second
it's robust many common buffer additives
and biochemical and cellular assays
which allows us to do a lot of assays
without any cleanup and again it can it
can see a lot of diverse metabolites and
analytes that we would like to see from
biological assays
so the the actual mechanism let me try
and describe that in in brief
um
The Matrix assisted Matrix refers to
water
and the IR is
uh we shoot an infrared laser at 2.94
microns which actually excites the water
vibration
so that that's what absorbs the energy
and and
um a plume of material is shot up into
the air when the laser fires
directly over the sample we have an
intersecting ESI spray so a normal ESI
spray going across the the where the
plume would come up from the sample and
into a mass effect Inlet so the droplets
merge the uncharged analytes coming off
the sample you get incorporated into the
ESI droplets pick up charge as they're
introduced in some aspect and then can
be analyzed
so this is that
um going from tissue slices as shown on
this slide to a micro tether plate as
shown in this slide is a very simple uh
conceptual jump and so that's that's
where we're trying to take this
technology
so here here's our current setup at Abby
um I'll I'll describe it in brief so we
actually have taken our the mass spec we
have a we purchased a q executive hfx
from thermal Fisher
we added a front-end stage onto it as
shown in the middle the stage is a just
has an XY this also has a twister arm
attached so we can feed plates to it uh
if you zoom in on the far right to the
the actual uh where the business happens
um you can see the electric spray coming
in we had to build a custom heated
extended capillary to be able to reach
the P Row the typical Inlet only reaches
about one inch off the mass spec so we
had to make a little over three inch
Inlet and we needed to ensure that heat
got to the end of that Inlet to
efficiently desalvate the droplets
coming in so if there's a custom
um Extended transfer tube
um there's a lens above that to focus
the laser and the laser itself is is
shown in the middle panel it's directly
above that lens shooting down we also
have Incorporated a plate Chiller under
the plate and we have uh um an hplc pump
for the electric spray spray emitter
so in addition to the Twister we
actually have Incorporated the the
rmaldezy onto our
um hi-res pod so we
have a track that can shoot a plate over
from the high-res pods shown on the
upper left where we have five other
slots that we can use for
um various equipment for running acids
so we can do fully automated cell based
and biochemical assays and shoot them
across to the maldez system for analysis
um so some some advantages of this setup
it only costs about fifty thousand
dollars to build the front after buying
the mass spec it only costs about fifty
thousand dollars to build the rest of it
so twenty thousand dollars for laser 20
for the stage and
um another 10 for additional components
and I'll at the end of this talk I'll
show you our next Generation model which
actually does away with the stage and
I'll explain how we're doing that
We Do It um aldezi itself has a
potentially couple not just to a thermal
q q executive hfx but various other Mass
Spec makes and models as well so we're
actively
um
working on coupling it to a triple quad
instrument and also we'd like to be
interested in putting it in time of
flight through protein applications
uh there is no sample transfer or costly
consumables necessarily we can directly
sample as I mentioned before from any
micro tighter plate 96 well 384 well
1536 well
um we don't have to put it into a
specialized plate which the the psyx
echo Ms would have to do
um so far we just have home built
software that controls everything so we
can control both the
um the syncing with the mass spec the
laser shooting with the for the data
capture that the plate movement and then
on the back end we have homemade home
built software to extract masses and and
Peaks and and process our data
it also allows us to do kinetic mode
um when the laser fires we're only we're
only ablating probably picoliter to
nanoliter amounts of volume so we can
sample the same well over and over again
and we we actually have sampled Wells
hundreds of times uh while still seeing
good analyze signals so that allows nice
enzyme kinetics and and other kinetic
Tech experiments to be done
so here's just a couple figures of Merit
um when when we run at at very high
speed we can we can actually run a
continuous motion that and sync the
laser to fire every time it is centered
over a well this the speed we can run is
actually directly dependent on
resolution of the mass spec so that's
shown in the The Middle
figure labeled B so when we're in
continuous motion low latency mode we
can get up to 22 Hertz uh real real
sampling at the lowest resolution so
resolution of seven and a half thousand
we can sample at 22 Hertz once we get up
to a resolution of 120 000 we're down to
in the two Hertz range
um
on the on the right is shown some heat
maps of plates where we're we're running
at high speeds of 22 samples per second
analyte analytes A and B are staggered
across the plate every other column and
you can see that we have very good
um detection of the analytes and no and
very little carryover so we have we see
typically less than 10 CVS when we
um use this an internal standard or a
substrate product ratio
and
um the the
middle graph on the bottom actually
shows the carryover of those analytes so
when we sample it uh the the x-axis is
actually sampling speed and the y-axis
is percent carryover so for sampling at
20 Hertz we're just starting to see 0.1
or 0.2 percent carryover so 20 Hertz and
that that relates to the lifetime of the
plume that comes up
20 Hertz is is probably our limit of
being able to sample without getting
significant carryover but that's playing
fast enough for most
um most assays and one other thing I
should mention is that if we do need
increased sensitivity we can we can slow
down a lot and we can overstamp since we
can't sample multiple times for a while
we can sample 10 even 50 to 100 times
and average that to increase our signal
the noise ratio I think the next slide
is a video showing real
um real time
uh use at the 22 Hertz so let me start
that
you can see it going at full speed now
it's going to slow down and now you can
it's almost
you can see the laser firing and
expecting data for every well
so that was that was 22 Hertz
um
real-time collecting data for every well
and this is just uh to show that we can
that the robustness of the system we
actually took three plates and we to
simulate a full day of high throughput
screening we took three plates that says
alternating Columns of reaction or no
reaction and we read the the plates a
hundred times each causing 30 seconds
between each three to simulate plate
movement
um and so in five hours we were able to
collect 115 000 Wells of data we didn't
see any signal deterioration or
increased background we we saw very
little carryover we got data for every
single well with less than 10 CVS by the
hundredth rate of the plates after had
been sitting out for an hour and a half
we did start to see
um significant hfx so the CVS went down
but obviously that wouldn't be the case
if we had a fresh play each time
um we also tracked carryover our median
carryover was 0.03 percent and uh better
than 95 percent of the wells had no
detectable carryover so this just
demonstrates that we can basically run
all day
um and we've had this system up for
about two years now and and other than
routine maintenance the uptime for the
instrument has been uh better than 95
that every once in a while it needs a
quick cleaning which takes that out of
commission for maybe two or three hours
okay so that's that's uh how the
instrument works now I want to take you
through a couple examples for
applications that were used in here at
Epi so I'm going to talk about
biochemical assays quickly and then cell
based assays and protein analysis but
there there are significant other uh
number of other applications that would
be of interest in in Pharma that where
else that we will be looking at in the
future
so first off is biochemical essays well
this is really a has been a slam dunk
for these we published a paper in uh
last year that describes it so I would
point you to that for more information
um this paper was actually published
before we we were up at full speed I
think we were running it about three to
five minutes per plate so three
um that's about one second per sample we
weren't running quite as fast as we can
run now but nevertheless
um
in that paper we showed that we can do
biochemical essays looking at a variety
of different substrate product pairs for
enzymes so p300 is a peptide and the
traditional assay used TR fret
the isoglyceryl kinase this has a lipid
product substrate product and the
traditional assay was ADP glow and then
isocitrate dehydrogenase looks at the
isocitrate
alpha-ketoglutarate conversion and that
the acid form aspect we used was a
couple fluorescence intensity acid all
these buffers were performed in their
standard biocom class a buffer meaning
they had they had buffer there they had
sodium chloride stress they had carrier
protein BSA between one of them had
between the DGK has 50 millimolar
beta-actyl glucoside so even high levels
of detergent and what we found was that
we get very comparable data with the
traditional assays and in some cases the
traditional Optical assay so either
fluorescence or luminescence
in the case of idh we actually got
clearly better data for idh the the
coupled assay was not amenable to use of
dtt or reducing agents we we were able
to run that with reducing agent with the
mass spec and we were able to get rid of
a lot of
um a lot of
nuisance compounds so we're currently
usually utilizing maldezi for
multi-throput screens and weekly SAR
support for biochem classes and it's
it's been a a lifesaver for some
projects
um the only one I'll go into more detail
on is and this is something that we're
still developing as well is specifically
of the biochemical cytochrome p450
assays so these are Workforce assays in
the admin space looking at
um
through our drug interactions so do
drugs inhibit uh the the cytochromes
that break down the Earth that
um
from the metabolism of drugs in your
body and So currently the the assay used
for that are typically a lot slower
their their Mass Spec based but they're
either either lcms which we do here at
Abby or some some companies use Rapid
Fire which is
um seven to thirty seconds per sample
we're using
um well Desi for this on the far right
side you can see the Maltese versus lcms
results for one plate of compounds you
can see we have very nice correlation
the left and the middle panels show
um limits of detection for two of the
most common dips zip three a four and
sip 2d6
um and on the the left-hand panel in
blue is limit of detection of the
product in pure water and then in the
assay buffer that we actually run the
assay and it's in red and then the after
a buffer Plus uh human liver microsomes
in the green but you can see we do lose
two orders of magnitude of sensitivity
but even at 10 nanomolar we still have
plenty of signal left and so we can run
the acid
so take your message from this is that
we're able to analyze uh six plates 696
well plates in five minutes versus the
20 hours currently uh used to analyze by
lcms
so that's that's a big win in the
biochemical assay space
so shifting Focus to cell assays
um we have
we have SIMPLE protocols for both
adherent and suspension cells briefly we
just plate the cells do our normal assay
when it comes time for analysis we wash
and that's that's optional it only
depends on if what we are looking for in
the cell is also in the media if it's in
the media of course we need to wash that
away
um
if they're suspension cells we
disappoint the cells and then wash them
um and then for license and extraction
we just add solvent so we had typically
we we had 20 microliters of methanol let
it sit for 30 minutes and then we add 80
microliters of water to fill up the
wells and then we analyzed by Iron
maldesi so again there's no plate
transfers we don't we don't have to
um
move into a different plate and then
shown on the bottom left is just an
example Spectrum from a549 cells this is
ten thousand cells at 60k resolution and
this is five shots averaged
in background subtraction subtracted in
red is positive mode and in blue is
negative mode and you can see there's an
abundance of of data so we we have very
high information Rich data this took one
second per well to capture with five
shots so in positive mode we have about
a thousand features that many of them
are are duplicates because they're
different cell that X but nevertheless
we have hundreds and hundreds of
positive mode analytes and in the
negative mode there's about 500 or so
feature features again hundreds of
analytes you can zoom in I've just
zoomed in to
um
five Dalton them over Z ranges on the
right hand side there so 385 to 390 and
700 to 705 and you can see we have
Baseline resolution for a lot of these
analytes so very uh very high data rich
and we can pick out a lot of analytes
so how are you how are we using this
um we we have a whole bunch of different
assays we're using this for now at AMV
um so shown on the left we can we can
look at nucleotide sugars so this is a
phenotypic type assay looking at neutral
side sugars and you can see when we
knock down the gene that
metabolizes that Sugar we see build up
um we can look at amino acids so in the
in the middle panel we're looking at
we're doing a glutaminase
feed the assay so we can look at the
glutamine to glutamate internal cell
cell ratio we're actually running a high
throughput screen of that right now for
publication
now we can look at lipids so and I'll go
into more detail of that on another
slide we can we can see lipid changes in
the cell we can label
uh we can add we can feed labeled
metabolites and track the label going
through metabolic flux and we can also
do phenotypic acids if we if we train
um frame the system with known compounds
so either an apoptosis inducer shown in
black and the far right or a ferroptosis
inducer we can track specific lipids
that only respond during ferroptosis and
then we can look we can add unknowns and
see if we can see those same lipids
changing
so a little more detail on the cell
assay so this is I mentioned the lipid
assay we were running this assay using
high content Imaging where we were
adding a alkyne reagent that would that
would
um click to the product of the lipid
product and then we could add a
fluorophore and seize localization by
Iron using arrows Desi we can
um directly see the lipid so you can see
in the far right if we add compound we
get that lipid product disappearing
compared to the DMSO treated sample on
the bottom
um interestingly yeah Ira maldezy also
offers additional insights where if we
if we take the subtraction of the
compound treated versus Dima so well and
average average those we can actually
pick up a variety of different lipid
species that are changing so we were
able to find five different lipid
substrates
for this this enzyme and if we check the
ic50 of this compound or ec50 this
compound for all five lipid substrates
they the average of those is the same as
the the high content
assay average which which would of
course be looking at all would not be
able to distinguish the individual
lipids
um for the sake of time I'm going to
skip through the metabolic labeling
example this is with isocitrate
dehydrogenase but I'm suffice to say we
can track that we can track one Dalton
changes going into the cell
and then uh lipids Downstream so I want
to move on to protein so this that the Q
executive hfx is actually uh has been
very nice for looking at protein we can
see recombinant purified proteins
anywhere from 13 kilo Daltons up to
antibodies in the 150 kilo down size at
Empire we've seen up to 200 kilos we can
do this again either desalted or in
buffer this tolerates
um a small amounts of buffer and we can
still we still get good signals from the
proteins
um however I do want to
um make give the caveat that we're not
able to see very complex mixtures of
protein so we we can't it because of the
ESI mechanism we can't pick out proteins
directly from cells with this this
ability to see proteins does give us the
ability to do quite a few applications
we can do high throughput glycoform
analysis so on the bottom in the in the
middle box you can see analysis of an
antibody so this is mismab if you zoom
in you can see multiple glycoforms if
you've got a reducing agent you can
actually see the heavy chain and light
chain
um coming apart and then if you zoom in
on the heavy chain you can see some of
those glycoforms
um
so
here's just
um an example of High super protein
analysis sorry the
um no
put their own button here we go here's
here's the example of high throughput
protein analysis this is uh on the left
is is data collected at one Hertz so one
sample per second and you can see we
have alternating columns instead of
chrome C and myoglobin we have the scale
yellow is one percent carryover so
um you can see that we have less than
one percent carryover in every single
well except for one for myoglobin
um and then sampling at 22 Hertz which
is the movie I'm going to show you in
the next slide uh we get we also get
good high quality data so let me show
you the movie for sampling proteins at
22 Hertz
and this is with our new new robot our
Gen 2 system
sorry I forgot the movies got out of
order and it's positive the the movie I
meant to show
so this this is sampling the
plate collects it turns green you can
see that that Spectra alternating
between the two proteins
so that plate Cooks takes
um 17 seconds to collect the data and
you can see this is our our home built
software on the screen you can see the
the data is collected and we can see
Spectra for all the proteins okay let me
go back to
[Music]
this slide
uh okay so that's that was we had a
collecting for the the
um proteins so I'm going to skip this
side uh so a couple more
um applications we can do we can do if
we have covalent compounds we can do
direct protein binding addict formation
some examples shown here is with BTK
which has a couple covalent drugs
available
uh so we can we can
um
track the the loss of protein signal and
and the the attic formation of fast fast
compounds or not covalent compounds by
using those covalent compounds as a
probe and so that's what's showing it
with Rebecca brute nib and pr1008 which
is actually is covalent but it's
reversible you can see we can see on
rates from from the order of
um in a table at the bottom
um very fast to
um very very very slow for Pierre n1008
sorry we're looking at off rates the off
rate is seven days
um for Rebecca brute nib the off rate is
on the order of
um less than a minute
uh and then the boxes on the on the
bottom right we can actually track both
translational modifications so this is
BTK again we're looking at
phosphorylation when we add ATP and you
can see the protein slowly
phosphorylating itself
and then in the right where uh one other
application we're interested in this
covalent fragment screening and so
here's an example of a set of compounds
comparing maldese and the x-axis versus
lcms are traditional way of tracking
covalent fragment screening on the
y-axis and there's good correlation and
for reversible covalence well Desi
actually works a lot better than lcms
because oftentimes the compound falls
off in the LC column
um
so one last protein application that
I'll I'll wrap it up we can also look at
direct addict formation of nuisance
compound so most hts's in the hit set
there will be a variety of nuisance
compounds that are picked up and we are
constantly looking for good assays to
weed those out so at Avi we have an
essay called alarm NMR where we're
looking at the lab protein which is a
small 12 killed on protein of multiple
exposed cysteines uh and by animar they
look for chemical shift perturbations
when they add compounds we can do this
also by directly by Ms we can look for
direct addict formation uh as shown for
the beta lactam and the top of the left
box
we see we see direct addict of that beta
Lake and we also see some oxidation 32
Daltons so two oxygens added
um and then on the the bottom compound
is the quinone and we can see direct
attic formation of that
um we can also with the QE Q executive
hfx we can do some limited msms
sequencing top-down sequencing and
identify which
um which cysteine or modification site
there is so
um we can do this with other systems as
well and this is a
a very nice tool to have for
characterization of HTS hits and
covalent hits
so I mentioned we have a Next Generation
system and that's shown here and that
was the other movie I showed earlier
which I'll go back to now
um so we've redesigned them all that's
the front end for increased flexibility
and ease of use so we no longer have a
stage um our engineer had the brilliant
idea to instead of using a stage and an
arm just use a six axis robot arm that
will access both the plate Handler and
Sample stage
um this is also actually fairly cheapest
less than twenty twenty thousand dollars
for the robot arm and then we've also 3D
printed a jig for the the extended
capillary tube and the ESI Inlet and the
laser mounting so that we can easily put
this maldesi front end on a variety of
different Mass Spec systems this
requires a different 3D printed jig for
for the different systems and how we
actually connect it but
um now we have a bolt-on carrot that can
go to various Mass Spec systems and
again the whole front end was under
fifty thousand dollars and this video
here is going to show you
working so here's the the robot arm
going to pick up the plate
from the plate storage area
3D printed jig with the laser coming
into the top the DSi is there and now
we're going row by row again
ah
so that's our that's our new system that
we're we're pushing out through Abby
um so just in conclusion to wrap up I
think I'm a minute over time
um actually I won't go to the
conclusions I want to acknowledge
acknowledge our team so this is uh uh
our team shown in the picture we also
have worked closely with Dr mutterman at
North Carolina State University
um we've had good impact from thermal
fissure and our laser was built by Jeff
Manny at jgm Associates and that is it
thank you I look forward to seeing your
questions by email